madame la présidente madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues je voulais
tout d'abord souhaité la bienvenue à
l'ensemble de nos collègues j'ai une
pensée en direction de toutes celles et
ceux qui ne sont plus présents dans cet
hémicycle et notamment à mon ami jean
lassalle
madame la première ministre je vous
adresse le façon républicaine mes voeux
de réussite je me réjouis de voir des
femmes occuper enfin deux grands postes
en responsabilité au gouvernement mais
aussi à l'assemblée nationale madame la
présidente
nous débutons ce mandat avec beaucoup de
gravité notre pays n'a jamais été aussi
fracturé au bord de l'implosion nous
sommes tous porteurs des messages des
angoisses de nos concitoyens nous devons
être aussi au niveau de cette
responsabilité
perspective de crise économique septième
vague du coc vite guerre en ukraine
montée des inégalités système de santé à
bout de souffle coût de la vie
exorbitant dérèglement climatique la
liste des menaces et malheureusement si
longue et nos concitoyens tellement
désabusés voire désespérés qu'ils
refusent de plus en plus d'aller voter
notre devoir est de les remobiliser pour
affronter ensemble ces immenses défis la
défiance est partout emmanuel macron
avait été lue en 2017 sur la promesse de
rassembler autour d'un projet de
modernisation
nous en sommes si loin
de cette réalité nous invite tous à la
modestie mais aussi à l'audace madame la
première ministre vous venez de tracer
vos grands axes d'action nous vous avons
entendus et seront très attentifs à leur
mise en oeuvre et à ce qui est
fondamental à nos yeux la méthode vous
l'avez compris vous ne pouvait plus
gouverner seul d'en haut est décidée
uniformément depuis paris des solutions
pour le pays et cette absence de
majorité absolue doit vous amener à
faire des compromis enfin et tant mieux
en vous donnant une majorité très
relative les français ont dit gouverner
autrement écoutez nous partager les
responsabilités
j'en appelle donc un nouveau pacte
démocratique qui suppose de rompre
radicalement avec toutes les pratiquants
vigueur depuis très longtemps et
renforcer ces cinq dernières années il
ya douze prêtres madame la première
ministre le gouvernement compte un
ministre du renouveau démocratique
vaste programme il pourra compter ici
sur de nombreux députés pour le réussir
s'il s'engage dans une cohue élaboration
tente il est crucial de presse de
préserver notre république revivifiée
ont d'abord le parlement dans ses moyens
et dans ses prérogatives
nous devons pouvoir travailler
correctement sollicité l'aide de
spécialistes pour nous éclairer sera
plus utile que la présence quotidienne
des gardes républicains
nous souhaitons également une plus juste
répartition des responsabilités comme
c'est le cas dans toutes les démocraties
qui nous entoure l'absence de majorité
absolue n'est pas vécue comme un drame
mais une opportunité pourquoi pas chez
nous nous voulons exercer pleinement le
mandat que les français nous ont confié
nous ne voulons plus être sous la
tutelle de hauts fonctionnaires qui
dirigent notre pays toujours les mêmes
qui prétendent toujours en savoir plus
que nous mais qui ne se sont jamais fait
élire nulle part la république ce n'est
pas la république parisienne c'est la
république des territoires
nous ne voulons plus légiférer dans
l'urgence notre pays croule sous les
textes bavard trop technocratique mal
écrit il étouffe sous les normes et la
concentration des pouvoirs arrêtons la
démocrate la bureaucratie les décisions
totalement déconnectée des réalités nos
concitoyens n'en peuvent plus revenons à
l'autre de l'autonomie à toutes nos
organisations
en commençant par l'hôpital
nous voulons de façon urgente renforcer
la participation citoyenne inspirez vous
des préconisations du rapport bernasconi
très intéressant remis à votre
prédécesseur en février dernier ouvrons
les droits de pétitions permettons à nos
concitoyens de nous saisir directement
utilisons le référendum mois sont
multiples n'ayons pas peur du peuple
français nous sommes ici pour le servir
refondons fin notre organisation
territoriale
j'en appelle un shop de décentralisation
pour cette véritable république des
territoires
pourquoi dans ce pays tout est concentré
toujours au plus haut niveau de l'état
la france est multiple diverses c'est sa
force c'est sa richesse la france est
belle ce sont nos territoires des plus
petits aux plus grands la france c'est
l'outre-mer trop souvent relégués au
second rang derrière les grandes
déclarations d'intention
transférer donc enfin est maintenant aux
territoires qui le souhaitent toutes ces
compétences que l'état n'arrive plus
exercer transférer les moyens financiers
qui vont avec et fait confiance enfin
aux élus locaux et ça ira beaucoup mieux
et beaucoup plus vite je veux à ce stade
évoquer la question corse que vous avez
mentionné et je le redis la solution
doit être globale économique sociale
fiscale culturel mais bien entendu
institutionnel c'est pas un vain mot le
processus initié doit conduire un statut
d'autonomie renforcée appelons un chat
un chat
je le disais les français attendent des
mesures exceptionnelles et urgentes pour
repenser l'offre de soins refonder un
hôpital à bout de souffle pour accélérer
la transition écologique pour voter
enfin une grande loi d'autonomie
dépendance trop de fois repoussée au
profit de nos personnes âgées
abandonnées
j'ai entendu également votre engagement
pour l'autonomie des personnes en
situation d'handicap
nous avons porté ces dernières années et
contre d'ailleurs l'avis du précédent
gouvernement un projet de déconvenues
gallisa sion de la hache cette réforme
doit être mené par tous les français
attendent aussi les mesures
exceptionnelles et urgentes pour le
pouvoir d'achat la brusque remontée des
prix fragilise les plus précaires et les
classes moyennes elles touchent certains
territoires plus que d'autres nous
attendons depuis plusieurs semaines de
nouveaux projets de loi nous regrettons
que vous n'ayez pas trouver une solution
plus juste plus ciblés plus efficace
pour protéger les français de la hausse
des prix du carburant vous allez
prolonger la réduction générale de 18
centimes d'autres dispositifs auraient
pu être créés et plus ciblée vers ceux
qui en ont besoin et je le redis il faut
mieux accompagner tous les ménages dans
la transition énergétique
la revalorisation est prévue sur des
retraites valent dans le bon sens mais
elles demeurent inférieures aux
prévisions de l'inflation prenons notre
que la revalorisation du point d'indicé
dans la fonction publique est
intéressante mais je veux insister sur
une ambition plus large repenser
l'ensemble des carrières des
fonctionnaires
à commencer par celle de la fonction
publique hospitalière et des enseignants
devons augmenter les petits salaires
c'est simple par le transfert de la
prime d'activité et le report du restant
de charges sur les hauts salaires
nous appelons aussi à diminuer
radicalement les frais bancaires
l'augmentation des loyers doit être
mieux plafonné vous en avez parlé madame
la première mini souvenons nous de nos
coûts nos compatriotes doivent tous
pouvoir bénéficier d'un logement digne
il convient donc de construire plus
massivement et de repenser l'aménagement
du territoire en défendant la ruralité
je pense à nos agriculteurs qui doivent
pouvoir vivre de leur travail de leur
installation jusqu'à leur retraite en
plein enfin nous appelons à des mesures
plus fortes encore en direction d
outre-mer la question de la vie chère si
pose avec davantage de gravité les
réponses avancées par le gouvernement ne
prennent pas la mesure des difficultés
rencontrées et de l'explosivité de la
situation les mesures pour le pouvoir
d'achat doivent être mises en oeuvre
sans que la dette n'explose davantage
nous n'avons pas de baguette magique à
la maison la dette progresse de 115 % à
50 115% du pib et une remontée des taux
signifierait les tremblements de nos
finances et de l'action publique ma
crainte c'est qu'au final ce soit les
français qui règlent l'addition la
participation des multinationales à la
solidarité nationale est donc nécessaire
je pense aux gains face aux grands
groupes pétroliers qui dégagent des
profits en hausse jouer enfin alerté sur
trois autres urgences qui menace notre
pays et la cohésion notre système de
soins durement affecté l'hôpital est au
bord de l'explosion les déserts médicaux
s'étendent nous avons pris bonne note
madame la première ministre de vos
propositions attaquons nous aux causes
profondes de l'exode des professionnels
de santé hors de l'hôpital la seconde
urgence ce sont nos jeunes logement
transport bourse accès à la culture ils
ont besoin d'un minimum vital garantie
et d'une orientation qui ne sera donc
pas en perdre qui ne relèvent pas en
permanence les moins aisés en seconde
catégorie à commencer par ceux des
territoires oubliés je terminais
évidemment sur une alarme le climat et
la biodiversité ou discours sont à la
hauteur mais votre action n'est pas
résolu à ces réseaux lui est assez
massive elle doit concilier quatre
impératifs le respect de l'environnement
le renforcement du progrès de nos
territoires et de la justice sociale
sinon rien ne bougera il faut donc
engagé un vaste plan de financement de
la transition énergétique regrouper les
dispositifs enfin et les décentraliser
quelle usine à gaz nous avons fabriqué
dans notre pays tout simplement parce
que nous avons pas voulu faire confiance
aux collectivités pour gérer tout ça et
plus de simplicité et d'efficacité
en conclusion notre groupe aborde la
législature qui débute avec
responsabilité et avec gravité notre
priorité être à la fois dans
l'opposition et force de proposition
dans le dialogue le respect de tous pour
donner enfin à notre pays une vraie
vision d'avenir madame la première
ministre vous avez conclu votre
intervention en disant la confiance ne
se décrète pas a priori elle se forgera
texte a pretext projet après projet mais
nous jugerons cet engagement sur pièce